so what begin today is we're going to
see an eclectic selection of endings and
compositions some from real games like
this one and some from compositions and
all of them have left a really serious
impression on me at one time or another
some of them I've seen relatively
recently within the last few years some
I've seen many years ago even when I
just started playing chess but all of
them in one way are not already affected
me and I have to tell you that whatever
you'll see in all those endings that
things those things happen in real games
first the games of course prove it by my
definition but even those that are not
just compositions some motif even not in
the most beautiful way as it's shown in
the composition they happen in games
happening in my games happen in games of
my students help me analyze help me get
better I really believe that looking at
those things is really really worth it
so let's start with an example from here
again we're doing it without any special
order you'll see that you'll see some
examples of tactics in the end games
some example of Zeus van some example of
simplification and tricks all kinds of
motifs that are not necessarily your
every day's bread-and-butter
some are simple so we have this kind of
a position with white you move and when
you look at the ending it's not an easy
ending by any means it's a pretty tough
ending sure you ever look against the
bishop and usually in a position where
two point were pawns on both sides of
the board that should be very strong for
the rock the rook is much more agile
than the bishop however the number of
the pawns is very minimal you can see
that black has serious pawns on the a
file and the King is already close to
the Jeep on so
when you look at it you think yourself
how to how to win it because for example
rook takes a five king g3 and you lose
the Jeep one after which th part is
gonna give you a little bit of hard time
so that's pretty much an instant draw
however you have to be sometime
imaginative even in reduced material
position you really have to appreciate
all the variables in the equation and
here I want that you I prefer that I
will always show you the solutions that
I want you to solve because some of them
are really convoluted and even if you
see the first or second move you might
still not see the rest
not in this example this example is
pretty straightforward so but what can
you tell me about this position I can
somebody say anything about this
position what looks anything that gives
you an idea of what to do if you were
white
like what's worth mentioning other than
the fact that it's a rook versus bishop
black has a pawn
the black king is boxed in that's right
the black the black king is boxed in and
that is a real big factor and that's
exactly what happened in the game he
maximized that idea
he played rook g6 and at first it looks
like something a bit crazy because when
you look at the position you think the a
pond is going to start running and what
made g3 King HP there's no maid however
after a four King comes on the dark
squares a3 King up for a two now it
looks even more dire than before because
how to stop the pawn you have to go
route k-6 after which maybe even before
doesn't look good for a white player but
if the King is already in a make nut so
Luke g3 idea Rock h3 checkmate so no
time to Queen and the problem is that
after Bishop e6 you simply play a check
and make beautiful resourcefulness I
mean and I'm telling you there are many
many compositions in game like this and
I can I'm telling in my students games
in games of people that I looked at in
my games there were always motifs like
this not always did they materialize
themselves because maybe the other side
also know not to enter a certain
variation with that but these things
just happen
so yeah white one nice thing let me show
you another example from the real game
this time it's a queen kneeling we're
gonna have several Queen endings on our
hands because Queen endings are really
rich with all kinds of tricks and
tactics and there's one of them that if
you don't enjoy that I'm just gonna quit
just because I think it's just so
beautiful this one is just very clever
so when you look at the position at
first glance you think that the first
player White has really good reasons to
be happy he is offering a trade of
Queens and it looks like black is now
like done if you do and down if you
don't if you trade you will lose to the
Past a pawn that's easy
if you move your queen I'm gonna take
Queen takes f7 that cannot be good news
by any means and if you try to check me
so that neither one happens I'm gonna go
key f6 and
again it looks like white is super
active here so at first glance you think
black is really in trouble
but again a little imagination and black
has a forced win actually in a very
beautiful Forstmann so what happens
again you have to notice black before
that the King is a bit short on squares
it has one two three four five six all
kinds of squares that he can go to but
many of those eight squares that usually
go through the either occupied illegal
to go to yeah basically only has one
move and also the queen is undefended so
it needs a little babysitting so black
played f6 check obviously and now of
course Queen takes f6 Queen g3 with a
better game so you cannot take King text
because you lose the Queen that makes
our task very easy King to g4 and now he
played Queen g2 check again black plays
the obvious move and white doesn't have
much to think about he played here
f5 Chuck only one move unless you want
to lose your queen and now he simply
seals the deal with not taking away the
last escape Square he plays d5 check and
resigned because if King takes you lose
the Queen if pawn takes mate really
brilliant just so nice and so aesthetic
and again something that repeats itself
in games this idea really happens a lot
with it is like you block an escape
square when people pieces take the last
escape score of a king or block tweest a
piece that really wants to defend so
again a very very aesthetic ending and
just when black looked like he was on
the critical list
he actually has a forced one okay now
it's gonna be a bit messy because I
haven't order it quite properly but
nonetheless we look at all of them it's
still nice okay this is this is a
favorite
White's on the move what to play here
again at first you think yourself well
that can be that difficult right because
white is up a night for a porn but we
already know that King rook and Knight
versus king and rook is not winning
unless you are really clumsy and there
are all kinds of threats so what did you
so the first move is obvious you have to
take the pawn if you don't take the pawn
then what are you going to do because
I'm gonna take your pawn in otherwise if
you advance if my King comes to it and
you have more losing chances than
winning chances so first takes and then
check and now what to do at first glance
again we want to play King g2
intuitively right but the problem is
that after King G to take stakes and
king c6 you cannot defend the pawn
anymore there is no way there's no no I
cannot stay on g5 if you could have
stayed on g5 you would have done it but
if you go 9 f8 I'm gonna go key d6 kini
7 and the point has to be let go
so this is the problem however why it
doesn't have to play King g2 is gonna
play king f2 excellent
exactly looks like a crazy crazy move
but this is such an aesthetic win and
again several motifs that just keep
repeating in endings in real games so
what else
and now here obviously ok
and now how many of you have ever seen
that famous ending by Barbier in
Saavedra when you have pawned King and
pawn versus king and rook and the King
and pawn win against the rock you push
the pawn and the rook keeps checking and
the key has to go to the right place
then you have to make a rock if you
haven't seen it I'll show it you very
briefly I thought everybody short and
you immediately recognized it but
actually you see the motif here but this
is the same kind of a market so rock
chuck and again you have to be really
smart about where you're going because
if you go to the G file ago root key to
so you have to go key f3 if you enter
the a file the e-file I'm immediately
going rock age 5 and rookie 5 when you
Queen
so you can never go to the e-file so he
needs to go king of three climbing so
chuck same thing check same thing check
you must check and again you have to be
very careful your Fingal to f7 you can
go to the G file because rookie six so
now time to go back and again kingi five
rook h1 and the rook is coming to the
e-file to secure the the pieces so watch
what happens here here here this is
already not not winning here here this
tricky motif keep repeating of rook
securing the king and queen just
beautiful I really find that amazing so
again I Auto accuracy is needed and King
f5 the King is going back so check yeah
notice there's no Knight g5 broke h8 and
you don't Queen so back you can never go
to the g4 the e-file so here here here
here now you go there because there's no
Chuck you cannot go you cannot go look
if there was Luke H - then you could
have done it but there isn't so Chuck
and now he goes this way zigzagging
check check check
and now if rook h1 you lose because
Knight f6 row here check and 95 and I'm
building a bridge and upon Queens nice
so alternatively you have to play check
and again you think dead end
if you go to the 7th run the rook takes
the knight and pinned you if you go to
the e-file I'm gonna go rook h1 if you
go King D for life I'm gonna keep
checking you however 9 f6 brilliant just
a brilliant ending now if you go ruk h8
I'm gonna go 97 and 98 cover the check
and I'm gonna Queen my pawn so you must
accept and now we dance back back back
back back
that's it and wins
just phenomena I mean this is like think
about somebody composing it it's just
really beautiful and let's see if I if I
is if it's gonna let me build a new
position on now that's it this is this
is it's actually it started as a white
to move and draw and black draws and
then somebody some reader that saw it in
a magazine in the 19th century found the
win so now it's named for both the
composer and the breeder the funder went
and the solution is c7 why is it
chirping sorry great
so c7 and now you must give Chuck you
have no other move so Chuck King here
again I can never enter the sea [ __ ]
then you're gonna go down and behind so
check King here Chuck King here check
King here now you think easy so nice but
wait
rook d4 and that was the initial
composition and it was to move and draw
because after c8 Queen I'm gonna go
rooks e4 Chuck
the queen is to take stalemate can you
see if Queen
Chuck takes stomach but he decided to
hey how do I make a rock that's really a
boy okay I'm gonna make a rock never
Queen right okay well we'll pretend this
is a rock I have to make a rock now I'm
threatening checkmate here so you have
to go look here and then King be three
wins because I'm attacking the rock and
threatening made here
so imagine again this is a rock so white
wins so I really said hey it's not a
droid so win and now the ending is named
for both of them so yeah very brilliant
ending okay next okay this is another
one of those position worlds like you
really have to use imaginations and I
can tell you that this is again
something that didn't came I will never
forget when I was in Holland in the
tournament there was a game between
David navara and Luke from Whaley and
also there this the same kind of idea
and I knew this error of this
composition
immediately said how black is gonna win
and everybody thought I was a genius and
then I said well it's just a non
composition and of course he won exactly
like that so but this this is a draw but
the winning idea is because didn't have
a drawing dubgame so why to move you
notice that this is really really tough
it's looking just very very unpleasant
what are you going to do if you go for
example King e6 you have to go key g8
that's the billion C but if you go King
e6 then here and now doomed if you go
here I'm just gonna go King III or h4 is
that's all - everything is winning so
that's bad or if you go and let's say
where else can you go if you go rook f7
I'm just gonna Queen if you sorry if you
go here I'm just gonna go here and now
the King can't cross and I'm just gonna
Queen whenever I feel like it and then
my pawn is gonna make another claim so
doesn't look good for white right but
white plays King g8 what a
counterintuitive move but you must go
behind the rock so h4 what else if
you're Kim reveals itself I'm just gonna
check it forever
if the King goes eight it goes out then
check and you eventually have to go back
so okay seven again if the King reveals
itself we're just going to check it
until it has to hide behind upon so now
comes this and in the aforementioned
game if you want to see it on the
database between navara it was one
really white against Navarre I believe
also I move like this stuff was the
winning move and the point is they
laughter takes King GTO and the pawn
Queens of the rook is attacked however
in this composition the difference is
and this is really good to know
because this can happen and it I've seen
it happen in Queen versus rook ending
that the row comes here and you must
Queen but this is a draw you cannot
escape it here you can never go to the
air file obviously and no matter how
much you zigzag like let's say you go
here check here no I'm always gonna have
these tables because my team protects
them so drop
despite the advantage over me so again
if you look at this position you just
really fantastic it looks so lost
because the king is such in a bad place
in f7 however if the King goes again the
counterintuitive move away from the pond
every person in the blood scheme would
have played King f6 or King e6 and of
course losing alright our next example
from a game again oh this is beautiful
maybe I should have kept it to the end
but I think you'll enjoy it anyways so
in this position white is up upon and he
of course he wants to win I mean he also
is kind of a dominating position but how
to continue perpetual he has but that's
not enough so watch what happens in this
game this is a game with all kinds of
mid block really tries his best but alas
again the beauty of chess wins so first
move f6 okay they analyze this variation
which is really kind of worth mentioning
if here check HERE then he goes King
eight seven can't draw yeah if you go
Queen it quidditch five is just bad but
here and of course that's it after check
I just take it
so f6 okay kind of an obvious move in my
opinion because what else can you do
right and now of course the deponent
thing is lost and if you play pawn takes
I'm gonna go key g6 and you're gonna get
maded because you have no checked so
black plays the only move that he has
left King h7 very very important move
and now amazingly wide blundered he
played F takes G seven after which it
was a draw but what should could have
done it just like it's really incredible
after this I'll show you the game first
Queen f7 stalemate if you don't take you
lose if you take a storm and just forgot
about that but he could have he could
have done something really really neat
he could have done never minded the
Queen ending after Queen of five wins
this is much nicer after f7 with a
threat of Queen f5 check winning
immediately now he tries Queen e5 they
only try but it's brilliant if Queen
takes Queen g6 checkmate
so you can take and you can about look
what happens g5 and now Queen takes f8
night wins just like steak having a half
you pieces in and what what wealth of
information it's like every movies a
message like III advance my porn you try
to second you queer I advance my point
you try to second you Queen
I give you my queen and then I win it
back just fantastic and again if you
think that there's other moves after g5
if there's just no checks that's the
problem
you cannot play g6 checked if you like
we need to check just brilliant just
fantastic really really a fantastic
realm and then okay next okay this is
again the idea of domination in the
endgame of course wife is losing
materially speaking however you will see
that he has chances again I have to see
that every time I look in this position
I swear I'm having like five different
Bashar boos about my own games like from
different tidbits not that something
happened that encompasses everything
that we see here but the motives that we
see here is like remind me of all kinds
of things that happen
a queen that's on h3 pawns that are
doubled here a material deficiency an
unsafe King all this we see often so
when you look at the position you think
yourself white is nearly lost really
because the queen is very very strong if
the Queen was let's say on e5 then it
would have been very fair for white who
just resigned he's going to lose all
these pawns and if he doesn't lose a
piece or a rook in the process it's
America so however the Queen is not very
well placed and as you can see of the
million Muslim as it doesn't really have
many can't go here can go here here here
here here can go here here here
basically have one move you can't even
go well you can go here but two moves
but you will see that this is quickly
taken care of so 96 check an obvious
first move King e8 check again an
obvious move and now if you go King to
d7 then rukia faith will just precisely
because the queen is now you're going to
get into assumes one here the Queen has
no legal moves except for losing it
I'm protecting my F corn I'm preventing
Queen a5 I'm just gonna run you out of
moves okay and I'm threatening Knight f4
or Knight g5 and you're just going to
lose the Queen so that's easy so he
tries his best then he goes here
okay so white plays the only move that
he has left rook b7 if you go rook f8
immediately oops sorry
then immediately you're in trouble
because my queen is gonna suck I'm just
gonna take here and after this horrible
horrible
so he goes check on b7 King has to go to
e8 if you go King to f6 then check the
rookies immune because if Knight g5 for
coming in Queen you'd have to go here
and then a 4 again I'm going to Zeus run
here here here you run out of moves
eventually you have to make a move and
you lose everything the key if the King
takes the pawn denied f4 and the key is
terminated in the queen is stuck so when
I run you out of pawn moves you lose the
Queen so he's gonna try a different move
obviously after this check he goes King
e8 so perpetual we have already we feel
very good we're not losing but again we
feel that with the Queen on h3 so stuck
who there's got to be more and of course
there is more and again the tactic work
Luke f7 the purpose is to keep the Queen
locked in can take the rock and again
trouble after 86 we just play okay here
does some tricks that we still have to
avoid watch this one because it could be
a mutual zooms line so for example if
Ruka 4g e7 a3 a5 a4 king here look here
King here stuck there's just no no good
move now so
after would be 78 Luke F 786 simply Luke
fa Chuck King b7 because King e7 just
neither for crops the Queen a3 a5 a4
King e7 9f four winds chopstick Queen
just fantastic motive of domination
the Queen has so many legal moves but
doesn't really have them yeah oh yeah
exactly if Queen d7 I should have
mentioned that of course but of this see
the program is always vocal about giving
checkmate so yeah all right next topic
again
this topic is pretty well known because
there's a very famous blitz game between
Lasker and capablanca maybe or I think
it was lost rapid Langa so you have this
kind of an ending looks really strange
two knights against the rock and okay of
course why does not worry about losing
can just take the pawn but if it takes
the pawn Knight d5 check and he loses
the rock immediately
so you think yourself okay what can I do
in this position what move are moves do
I have to do and if you just move my
knight will take the pawn on d5 then the
other knife is going to join him by
coming out it's gonna be a very simple
arm draw but we want to win with white
so again it takes a dosage of
imagination here to understand the first
move but rook e8 probably with the most
counterintuitive move in the position
and again watch the examples that the
commentators give we already said about
rugby 695 if here here here looks pretty
nice
however check and here you're not gonna
win this one
at the very least I'm going to sack one
night for the forum when wind upon on v3
with the other night so you are
however watch how beautiful this is rook
e8 well United's a bit trapped so you've
got to take and now King d8 up two
nights but the pawns and the King again
a very nice example of domination after
king here here and you're just not in
time they're taking here takes you have
three points at this you can end up with
one good one so notice how annoying is
when the King can't cross he has to go
like here yeah okay
here's another ending that comes a lot
in chess games the motif definitely
happened so much bishop against Knight
of course the bishop is much better than
the knight also kind of semi dominating
in and especially with the pawns are
this past form like in this case H pawn
and white to move in win still it takes
a little bit of creativity here to bring
the point home so it's a what to do the
first move is obvious you have to push
the passport if you don't push the past
form I'm just gonna go something like f5
if I get to play a 5 of course is gonna
be like pretty much a quick draw
so h5 now you are running out of choices
because I'm very fast you know that you
don't have time to play King King f8 h6
you're going to be stuck immediately so
you must play f5 and white of course
pushes the pawn and you must chase it
and of course if I push the pawn you
block me so I have to take so up to here
it's normal and again this motive is
very very important to remember that
King here and King that is just
completely dominated by two pawns you
can never take this one because this one
runs and you can never ever approach the
other that means that the King is
paralyzed there is a beautiful example
of this of an ending like this that
starts with some position to get to that
and the opponent has three passed pawns
on the other side so imagine that there
are three black pawns like here here and
here
versus the king itself and with accurate
play the pawns just can't make it
eventually you just fought them to
create some sort of a triangle and you
stand on b5 and black cannot move his
King has to give all these pawns away of
course white is just winning it's like
two points against five and wins
I remember I was seeing it as a child it
was amazing okay now of course the King
can move so Knight a6 is the only move
not really much not much else to to see
so King b5 again looks like well what
are you doing you're gonna lose you're
not you can lose your bishop but you'll
see that again domination if my knight
is allowed to go like out I'm gonna
easily
just go like here and then here and then
here blocked the pond and I'm going to
take all forms easy to run so you gotta
be brave and give the bishop and he has
to take it because where is he gonna go
Knight b8 I'm gonna go take that night
without any respect and then just win
the ending so 97 King has to go to c5
notice that even still there are tricks
if you rush to go here takes and after
this King takes why because if eight
seven nine f6 check fork the King and
upon so you it's amazing how many
nuances there are in those compositions
so the right move is that you have to be
patient you have to play King c5 and
only after takes now we'll see the other
variation if 96 King c4 97 Bishop c6 the
knight is dominated here here here here
what a beautiful even even to the last
move again Bishop is the rock with the
wrong rook pawn the bishop is the
opposite square but again you get the
position where the King cannot move you
can push the pawn and I'm just gonna run
with my king and stop it elegantly
beautiful just fantastic so yeah so
after king c5 he has to take and now
king c6 that's it no moves if you go
Knight g7 I go 87
if you move your king I'm gonna go 87
and any Knight move elsewhere is just
he's just going to lose the knife so
just thinking a beautiful idea of
domination look at this domination you
up at night all I have is two points you
can take one of them and you can take
anything you can get closer buy at a
pawn and my king is so out of the
picture it seemed just when I look at
those positions I found it so aesthetic
and again these things like I said for
the ten-time these things really happen
in games alright pick I have two more
example three more examples for you
let's take a look at this one this one
some of you might know it this is really
kind of a messy but
with all kinds of the behind the scenes
variations are maybe no less beautiful
than than the actual solution so why'd
you move what did you even though you're
up a rookie tonight obviously the black
part is about to Queen and you have some
urgency but again you can notice that
with the white king on d3 the black king
is a bit cramped maybe you can take
advantage of it so let's start with the
variation the corrector Brooksie to
check if you start with this eye queen
93 check King a - not King B 1 because
rook c1 and then you should you should
see the start again the behind-the-scene
variation here by the way King 8 you
just immediately Israel but if you play
King b1 rooks you want here check here
have to guard the Queen takes takes here
the pawn must advance and mate we saw
that last week those of you who attended
last week might remember that shown some
more tears like this amazing even
without pawns even without pieces the
night against upon still mates so ok
therefore we have to start with rook c2
because yeah and then now again you have
to be very accurate King b3 is the only
move if you go key B 1 the night goes to
a 2 or D file is the same thing and
after Queen make toward up made Patrick
takes takes here here and wins so
because rook is coming the other way
so he plays King III
only move now you must screen because as
we already seen I think in the other
variations right we saw this variation
here here looks familiar
so we've seen that so he has to Queen
takes King b2 and now only one move and
you think this have okay obviously have
to move the rook on the first ring but
what does it matter why should I go
Brooke f1 y naught E 1 or G 1 or H 1
looks like what can be the difference
the difference is that don't black
Queens and he's going to have moves
along the a file you have to be able to
put the rook in the place where the
Queen cannot dominate it so watch what
I'm talking about the rule goes to f1
only move and here's the reason a to
kisi for Queen what else I'm about to go
93 Czech Queen I go check only move
check only move check and now key a3
just forged a king in Queen King c1 okay
very easy 92 check King be one king here
the Queen on a1 doesn't look happy so
you basically have to go after this
check you have to go King be one king b3
and now you understand why the rookies
on on F was in the fr because if the
rook was elsewhere then my queen could
have played either here or here and if
the and then I would not allow you to
check me now it's just over just whims
pretty impressive I mean when you think
about the starting position sure you up
a night and an end a rock you think
yourself yeah that should be enough but
those pawns are really menacing but
there's like so many different cute
mates again with just absurd situations
the night meeting the king
those of you came late should see it
it's really really nice after Chuck here
here not the operation behind the scenes
king b2 here Queen check check
takes and here wins yeah okay I think we
have two more positions to look at this
I remember seeing a long time ago and
this really floored me I couldn't
believe my eyes I mean this is like of
course I was very just naive at a time I
have only new things that are obvious
but when I looked at this position it
just I saw the solution I didn't have a
chance to solve it off first and I'm
thinking to myself huh
what not possible but nowadays maybe a
little more refined with much more
literature maybe some of you might come
up with it so this is a way to move in
win and of course generally speaking
rook and Bishop versus rook is a
theoretical draw especially when those
pawns on the board even easier so if you
go with the obvious let's say Bishop e5
check in the a through p7 checking c8
you know where because I'm gonna go f5
and my rook is gonna come out and it's
nothing so again you think yourself how
to win and the first move is just like I
mean even today even from looking
backwards it's like unbelievable
the move is Bishop f5 what are you
serious it's like even now that I know
the solution aha you see like I was it's
almost like seeing a movie where the
here is about to die and you've seen it
you know it's gonna die and you're like
man maybe not gonna die but it still
died so it's like you see the movie you
know the movie still unbelievable that
this movie still played Bishop a5 like
such can you think of a more
counterintuitive move like in the kids
class if somebody goes Bishop g6 you
just like roll your eyes yeah we know
that but even they wouldn't play Bishop
a5 it's like it's re crazy just
incredible well the good news is that
the promis'd had to take because there's
no more I have five I stopped that fine
so what else is there and now you see
five again not too many moves rook GA
proc h8 I'm not gonna check you and King
da King b8 then I'm just gonna go King
d6 and again rookies lost or may so
gotta play have sex then I'm gonna go
here
again not that many moves to apply rook
g8 if rook f7 that's a problem because
rookie a check the rook just took away
the last escape square so room here King
here threatening you make them rock if
you go King d8 then you lose a rock if
you go here then here so ecstatic I mean
this is like take a look at this first
position one more time this is more for
me than for you so I'm looking at it and
I'm like what Bishop f5 attack suck
fantastic so yeah okay they also show
other lines like if here here here here
nothing Rock up six so the draw however
the ship f5
this is really fantastic alright
and our last position for the day is
going to be this one again
resourcefulness in the end game this is
how I call it you look at this position
and the first inclination is that white
is just lost it looks closed I mean the
king is just not coming closer my king
is just playing pacman eating the poor
knitting denied even if you second I'd
for one point I have another pawn plus a
bishop has to be lost
however know somehow white draws this
incredible so take a good look at just
you already know the answer have you
seen before you now try it you figure
out the last one star okay so key III
the point is if not g3 King H to here
here precisely winning yeah so gala be
resourceful sir King III okay so takes
still looking even worse than before
of course King f2 any other move Knight
f2 g3 just winning the pond so he have
to and the point is that after this here
zooks fine if you could say pass without
allowing white to pass you'll be in good
shape because King f2 key h2 however
know that doesn't know it not all it
worked if the bishop moves I'm just
going to take your pawns Backman style
they take g4 then take G Phi and after
King g1 still man no
the other back now and here it's just
tell me just fantastic beauty of just
really really nice you look I mean if
you saw this position on in the
tournament here and you looked at it uh
you would say come on like he's wearing
obviously is winning but sometimes just
resourceful it just to think about
something that is really think about it
impulsive how you gonna get stalemate in
this position with everybody has like a
million moves but you combine two ideas
paralyzing the double points and the bad
position of the bishop and the stomach
so after here here here if you have to
let go of both points it's funny you
don't lose one point sometimes you you
lose one and you get to defend the other
here no you lose both and alternatively
I draw this way so I think this is all I
have to show you guys today let me see
if I skip something I don't think I have
this concludes the lecture on that's
alright today